[Music]
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness features some very high profile
deaths whether it was a famous mutant or
a superhuman king who lives on the moon
here is every superhero that died in dr
strange in the multiverse of madness
not even doctor strange himself makes it
out alive of doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness although it wasn't
the earth 616 version of steven strange
who ultimately met his maker but several
variants that said the main universe's
sorcerer must be looking over his
shoulder a lot more after witnessing his
multiverse selves crumble before his
eyes right at the start of the
multiverse of madness a strange variant
bites the dust after a fight with a
demonic creature his body is then
transported to earth 616. eventually his
corpse ends up becoming a reanimated
zombie used to stop the scarlet witch in
the finale
i don't even want to know
a flashback also showed how earth 838
strange was obliterated by black bolts
after becoming too obsessed with the
darkhold then to solidify the belief
that all bad things happened in threes
the 616 strange had to put a stop to
sinister strange
after all the disappointments and hurt
suffered in her early years it appeared
as if wanda maximoff had found her own
ray of sunshine in the form of vision
and the avengers after the events of age
of ultron but it wasn't meant to be as
sanos power ripped away everything that
mattered to her the suffering this
caused trapped her in a darkness that
gave rise to the scarlet witch one of
the most powerful beings on earth
scarlet witch was responsible for the
deaths of nearly everyone on this list
as she tried to create her own perfect
reality in the end though she realized
that her methods had turned her into the
kind of monster she despised faced with
what she had become she destroyed the
dark hole in every universe and
destroyed the ruins of mount wondergore
burying herself under the rubble there's
no guarantee that wonder is well and
truly gone since this is the comic book
movie world and deaths are about as
permanent as robot tattoos if this was
her last appearance though at least she
died as a hero and not the villain
comic book movies can be extremely cruel
dr strange and the multiverse of madness
marked the third time that we witnessed
patrick stewart's charles xavier die on
screen first we watched him be vaporized
by jean grey in x-men the last stand
then he made us all ball our eyes out as
he met his demise in logan and now this
professor x is quickly becoming the sean
bean of superhero films much like his
other portrayals xavier was prepared to
die for what he believed in the
multiverse of madness while the rest of
the illuminati wanted to stop the
scarlet wedge through the threat of
violence charles tried to reach out to
wander through her mind and reason with
the troubled magic user what he found
was a real wonder trapped away in her
mind as a scarlet witch took over her
body professor x was also close to
liberating her from the power of the
darkhold the scarlet witch proved to be
too powerful for him in the end and
snapped his neck in the psychic world
sadly the consequences of this violent
act were fatal in the conscious world as
well
marvel fans received a memorable mcu
moment as leshana lynch's maria rambo
appeared as captain marvel the spelling
or theories that it was tom cruise as
the invincible iron man in the trailer
footage however this was earth 838
version of the character not the main
universe's captain marvel who is
presumably still carol danvers it was a
nice tribute to maria who was introduced
as danvers best friend and went on to
found the alien intelligence agency
sword plus it laid an excellent
foundation for the marvels as maria's
daughter monica developed cosmic powers
in one division unfortunately captain
marvel flew too close to the sun in the
multiverse of madness as scarlet witch
crushed her with a giant pillar while
maria's powers were as impressive and
fiery as expected she was no match for
wonder in the battle out of all of the
illuminati members she was the one who
put up the most resistance but her
biggest failure was the same as the
others they underestimated just how
powerful the scarlet witch really was
sometimes trailers spoil the biggest
surprises the illuminati will see you
now
that's what's happened in the case of dr
strange and the multiverse of madness
many fans predicted the arrival of
captain carter in the movie thanks to
one of the final trailers that showed
off the iconic shield it wasn't the
first time that we saw peggy carter as a
super soldier as she flung the mighty
shield in what if as well that said
there was something special about seeing
hayley atwell's captain carter in live
action while earth 838's cap put up a
valiant fight against scarlett's witch
and even utter the unforgettable i can
do this all day phrase the shield ended
up being her downfall it worked as a
weapon when cap flung it around and used
it to bounce off enemies and walls but
it also demonstrated how dangerous it
could be if it wasn't caught on time
let's put it this way after this
incident there were two caps in earth
838 and neither of them was much for
fighting the only good news is captain
carter will still show up in future
episodes of what if
it finally happened the casting that
every mcu fan demanded the office star
john krasinski as reed richards for
years fantastic four fans have wondered
when and how marvel's first family would
debut in the shared cinematic universe
and the answer arrived emphatically in
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness the stretchy superhero appeared
as part of the illuminati and did his
best to hold scarlet witch in her tracks
but wonder turned mr fantastic into her
own personal play-doh and ended his
brief appearance in the movie expectedly
many fans are wondering if this will be
a one-and-done deal for krazynski's
richards and the mcu considering how
vocal the people have been about this
casting in the past and how well
received it was by the general audience
it would feel like a missed opportunity
if marvel studios didn't introduce
krasinski as earth 616's mr fantastic as
well the only question is who will be
making up the remaining members of the
fantastic four maybe his wife emily
blunt might suit up a susan storm even
if she claims to not be interested in
superhero movies
come find me when you wake
while abc's inhuman series was far from
a resounding success and constantly
cited as one of the mcu's biggest misses
anson mounts black bolt received a
chance at redemption in dr strange in
the multiverse of madness introduced in
a comic's accurate costume and as a
member of the illuminati he only showed
up for a brief moment in the film
however it was arguably a much better
depiction of the character than the
first time he met the big shot of atalan
in the 2017 television show while fans
found out how destructive a whisper from
black bolt can be and reed richards
threatened to unleash him on scarlet
witch if she didn't back down the
inhuman's death quickly became an online
meme after the film's release wonder
magically stitched up black bolt's mouth
causing him to panic make the slightest
of peeps and blow up his own head
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one